hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
it is somewhat elo di prima Secunda
question 2 article 6 Thomas Aquinas is
going to consider whether pleasure could
in fact be human happiness or not and
he's going to provide some arguments for
that which are called objections in the
text and then he's going to clarify the
issue and tell us why pleasure although
it is a good cannot be human happiness
as such and this is a very common
doctrine Thomas you know brings up you
know some some examples from ancient and
medieval philosophy it was a big issue
back then people thinking that if I
could just have a life of enjoyment I
would truly be happy it's a very common
issue in our own time and it was during
his own time as well the so-called age
of faith because human nature is
attracted to to pleasure and Thomas is
going to give us some you know reasoning
why that's the case so why do people
think pleasure is happiness these aren't
the only possible reasons that one could
come up with but these are the ones that
Thomas considers he says since happiness
is the last end it's not desired for
something else but other things for it
but this answers to pleasure more than
anything else and he quotes Aristotle
it's absurd to ask anyone what is his
motive and wishing to be pleased wishing
to have pleasure so a pleasure and
delight these would be then what it is
that we most genuinely desire and then
that would be happiness if we can
actually get it and sustain pleasure
over time now that's an interesting
argument and we'll come back to that in
a bit
he also talks about it in a more
metaphysical way there's an analysis
that's going on here that's quite
interesting he says that the first cause
that is the cause that's you know
beginning something and causality goes
more deeply into the effect than the
second cause and he's quoting this day
Kazu s which is a pseudo Aristotelian
work he says now the causality of the
end consists in attracting the appetite
so Thomas uses Aristotle's four causes
formal material efficient and final the
final is the end the thing that is
drawing something the purpose the goal
and so the most final end is happiness
now Aquinas tells us something very
interesting here he says that seemingly
that which most moves the appetite
answers to the notion of the last end
and this is pleasure why he says well a
sign of this now this is an expiry and
experience that we can certainly relate
to is that delight dalek taught Co so
far absorbs a human beings will the
Faculty of will Volant us and reason rot
Co that it causes that person to despise
other goods so pleasure
or the promise of pleasure as he says
absorb in Latin it's actually absorb it
right
that's a cognate there it takes us in it
you know you could say swamps us it
takes us over and says leave that stuff
alone
go get that right there because that's
going to give you pleasure and although
we do have you
freewill and we do have a powerful
intellect or you know Faculty of reason
it's quite possible for pleasure to take
us over in that way is it not the
appetite for pleasure
so that would be saying that the the
human beings last end the most you know
fundamental the first cause which is the
last end would be pleasure the third
argument is a little bit of a weaker one
what all desire is best
since desires for good what do all
things desire delight or pleasure
delicto Orval up to us both wise and
foolish and even irrational creatures
therefore pleasure is the best of all
therefore happiness which is the supreme
good consists in pleasure were this to
be correct than hedonism would be the
correct moral philosophy Thomas doesn't
think that's the case and so what's the
basis for this so Thomas's engages in an
analysis here that's a bit more it's
it's less like the earlier you know
arguments about wealth or honor or
anything like that it's more about the
essence of human beings he says that
first of all he points out because
bodily delights are more generally known
the name of pleasures been appropriated
to them although other delights excel
them and yet happiness does not consist
in them so he's making a distinction
between bodily pleasures and what we
could call spiritual or mental pleasures
bodily pleasures or what everybody knows
including irrational animals mental
pleasures may be known to some degree by
by you know some humans but can be known
much more by by other humans it's the
difference between wisdom and
foolishness now as he tells us every
delight is when he calls a proper
accident so we need to think about what
that means he says in everything what
pertains to its essence is distinct from
its proper accident so what is the
essence
essence is what makes us what we are or
what makes this piece of truck what it
is right things have essences according
to Thomas a proper accident is something
that is distinctive to that sort of
thing but is not actually of its essence
so he has the example here of you know
human being can be defined as rational
animal and that is an indeed rational
mortal animal that is indeed what what
Thomas takes to be the human essence a
reasonable animal an animal that laughs
an animal that that has a sense of humor
he takes to be a proper accent a proper
means that its its distinctive of that
particular kind of thing right so we
could say you know this is a you know
it's got an essence of some sort
whiteness is not really a proper
accident because there's all sorts of
other things that are white I don't
actually have any white things on me
right now I mean I do have this ring
which is silvery which is canta white so
let's pretend that it's actually white
right it was printed it was plastic ring
so well whiteness is not a proper
accident neither is being cylindrical
but maybe there are some proper
accidents of truck but there are proper
accidents of human beings that can be
connected to their essence but are not
their essence so what's the upshot of
this for pleasure he says we must
consider that every delight is a proper
accident arising from or resulting from
happiness or some part of happiness so
it's not happiness itself it's something
that results from happiness it arises it
flows from it it's a byproduct if you
will but it's not a byproduct as
something that's purely accidental
something that's totally disconnected
from it it is it is you know involved
with with happiness so he tells us why
is this the case a person is delighted
why because they have some fitting good
a bonum convenience something that is
appropriate to their name
so you know for example we like maybe
taking baths right and sitting in the
Sun and so that is appropriate to our
nature in a certain sense although you
could live your life without taking
baths you know you just take showers
instead you know and maybe you take
vitamin D instead of going out in the
Sun but you know a crocodile the way
that it lays in the mud and waits around
for something to eat and enjoys the Sun
and stuff like that that wouldn't be
that Pleasant for us I mean unless you
imagine yourself to be a crocodile right
some sort of a crocodile cosplay or
fetishist or whatever it happens to be
right there's a lot of things or you
know another great example perhaps more
on point deer love eating you know
various vegetation that that we don't
really eat and in part because our
mouths are not adapted for it and if you
eat the stuff that they'd be like oh
this tastes like crap I don't want to
eat this but if you did manage to chew
it up which would be hard to do and then
swallow it your stomach is not set up to
process cellulose deers are you know
what's good for them what produces
pleasure for them doesn't produce
pleasure for us so you know the bonum
conveniens the good that is befitting to
us in some way and now here Thomas makes
a bunch of different distinctions these
are good to keep in mind so he says the
reason why I were delighted is we have
some fitting good either in reality in
actuality or in Hope which is projective
we already take pleasure in things that
we don't have or in memory we remember
back to pleasures that we did have so we
have past present and future there and
he says a fitting good if it is the
perfect good is happiness right so the
big H happiness is one fitting good if
it's imperfect it's a share of happiness
it's a portion of happiness either
proximate near nearby or remote and then
he says or at least apparent we can
think that some things play a role in
happiness
be wrong about that and take pleasure
when we hope that we're going to get
them of course when we do get them then
we're not going not quite so happy are
we so that really helps us out when
understanding pleasures of the mind he
says it's evident neither is delight
which results from the perfect good the
very essence of happiness but something
resulting from it as its proper accident
so pleasure is connected with happiness
but it's not happiness itself and if the
person did get what is happiness itself
which for Thomas is going to consist in
relation to God and they weren't they
weren't enjoying that that would be a
sign that there's something wrong in
that case right and when you they
wouldn't be seeing that as a bonum
convenience when it comes to bodily
pleasure he says bodily pleasure cannot
result from the perfect good even in
that way why because it's apprehended by
sense which is a power of the soul which
power makes use of the body the good
pertaining to body and apprehended by
sense cannot be our perfect good what
the rational soul excels the capacity of
corporeal matter again we're getting a
metaphysical analysis here right the
part of the soul which is independent of
a corporeal organ has he says a certain
infinity at unlimitedness in regard to
the body in those parts of the soul
which are tied down to the body and then
he says the things that we perceive
through the senses and derive pleasure
from those are singulars and it might be
useful to think of an example here think
about eating a chocolate bar if you like
chocolate you know some people don't
some people are allergic to it as well
let's assume you're not and it's
whatever favorite bar you've got alright
so you eat a bit and you chew it up and
you're tasting it with your tongue and
there's other things going on you know
your sense of smell is involved there's
probably other things going on as well
that are contributing to the total
enjoyment of this bite of the chocolate
bar then it's going to take another bite
right those are singular experiences
that you're having now you can try to
remember to yourself what it was like to
chew on the chocolate bar and
and how good of a memory you are good of
a memory you have you can you can awaken
that more or less you can anticipate
what it's going to be like but it's
always going to be all the sense things
are singular and they don't last over
time and you can enjoy this one without
enjoying this one you know you have to
put them all together into sort of a
continuum if you want to keep enjoying
it for a long time that's not really
happiness for for Thomas right
he says sense knows the singular the
intellect which is a power independent
of matter knows the universal it's
evident that the good that is fitting to
the body in which causes bodily delight
by being apprehended by sense is not our
perfect good but is as a trifle compared
with the good of the soul so bodily
pleasure he says is neither happiness
nor a proper accident of happiness the
way that spiritual or mental pleasure is
a proper accident of happiness so when
we consider pleasure we see that
pleasure is not going to be good we
think it's good that we we do consider
one of the responses to the objections
he says that we can ask ourselves a
questions is it delight or pleasure that
we really desire or is it the good thing
the object as he calls it using it in a
somewhat different sense of that delight
the thing that's going to give us that
delight we really want the good and the
pleasure that results from that is sort
of it like I said a side product it's a
it's a as thomas was calling a proper
accident and effect of that so delight
he says is desirable for something else
the good which is the object of that
delight and consequently as its
principal and gives it its its form so
you know we can go on as well and look
at some of the other objections he tells
us that the via ments of desire for
sensible to right delight arises from
the fact that the operation of the
senses are more perceptible since we
learn the senses early
you're on it's easy for intellect and
will to get drawn in that doesn't mean
that that's how things ought to go and
then finally his third reply says all
desire delight in the same way as they
desired good and yet they desire delight
by reason of the good not conversely so
it doesn't follow that delight is the
supreme and essential good but that
every delight results from some good and
some delight results from that which is
the essential and supreme good so again
we see why pleasure itself cannot be
human happiness as such although it has
a very close connection to human
happiness as at least in terms of the
mental pleasures as being a proper
accident of enjoying the good
you